so our first speaker this morning is
Italian HP from Hebrew University and he
will talk about the default like cereal
tell us about your sights all right good
morning thank you Fritton and I was
actually as some of you may have noticed
I had another title in the land but so
exactly I have two talks which I which
could fit this this workshop one is on
application information theory to
control and to actually in neural data
analysis and and but after hearing the
talks in the first two days and the
issues the trade was variety I decided
actually to go back to something I've
been talking quite a lot about in the
past year and and will talk and but
which made some sort of buzz in the
machine learning community in the last
year which is some sort of I believe a
deeper understanding of deep neural
networks and and since many of you are
using deep learning all over the place
and and there were several talks already
on trying to interpret what different
exactly telling us about data but neural
data I thought that the theory is
sufficiently interesting and not that
many who never heard about it to
actually connect it with biological
brains and since we have relatively long
time the second part of my talk I'll go
back through the data but at least what
I believe this type of analysis is
telling us about the brain so I don't
have in this community to to remind you
the fascinating history of deep neural
networks but you know for people like me
I've been around actually been thinking
about neural network since the mid 80s
since the whole field model essentially
this is quite a roller coaster which
which is a fascinating than it's a piece
of history and the fact that it's coming
back again in in some new ways and in
this new version of many layers
and it's doing some sort of miracles
that to to the f2
essentially everything in machine
learning vision speech and language and
natural language processing but by
informatics control whatever you want in
and also in many versions of this story
and in many layers within with feedback
without feedback with all sorts of
different architectures this clearly
requires some sort of theory I mean the
frustrating part of the story of deep
learning is that we all knew that it's
there it didn't work that well in the
80s there at least not simply saturating
in performance some sense and and but
with the emergence of much larger scale
problems I mean the problem grew up by
at least two or three orders of
magnitude in terms of the size of the
inputs and and and the competence of the
data and of course the power of the
computation and we're actually in a
different game now in my in my opinion
and essentially the old idea is that we
some of us started to think about in the
late 80s I mean the statistical physics
of of neural networks which is a very
different from the flavor and in
principle from the kind of theories that
people use in computer science because
it's not the worst case bound on
internalization it's not distribution
free it's it doesn't have all these nice
features of of the standard theory at
least in the machine learning theory but
this type of typical behavior
large-scale problem last scale analysis
becomes a much more relevant now and
actually argue that this is the way to
think about the neural networks in it so
for me this is bringing me back to the
80s but and some of the old ideas that
we started of conceived then become very
relevant today
so essentially you know since the late
2000 2006 seven eight nine when deep
neural networks and with in the hands of
you know
Jeff interning and his people and young
lacunae and few others and I started to
revolutionize machine learning there was
actually two types of approaches one
okay you know this seems to work and
let's use it everywhere we can and don't
ask too many questions about why it
works it definitely don't try to
interpret it in any any any sensible way
few people very few people were very
concerned about the fact that it works
so well and we don't understand it I
mean this is not the way you want a
theory of a fundamental theory of
machine learning to live life so I got
back to this actually with some people
about five years ago with Naga we
sitting here and later on with with
Aveda XIV who is responsible for many of
the simulations and then analysis that
we can show you today and it's actually
revisiting an old idea that in the late
90s we call the information button ik
method which is essentially I can say I
thought about it in the context of
speech recognition actually I mean this
should be the right way of extracting
the relevant feature out of a high
dimensional data with a lot of
irrelevant dimensions and speeches
certainly speech speech in the context
of text to speech speech to text it is
actually very much like this I mean
there there is a very high entropy
variable which we call the speech and a
very low entropy variable which we call
the text and the question was how to
reduce the excess entropy in the speech
signal to the to tell us exactly what we
need to know about the text this is of
course true also for any problem you
know in envision you want to label the
face you want to I mean this is really
the standard structure of the problem
and so essentially we are talking about
networks which have a very high entropy
input like pixels of an image and a very
low entropy output label which can be
just one bit and and the question is
okay what's actually happening in
enduring
this cascade of transformations of
representation no I'm stalling sometimes
I see people feel asleep coming so I
think you think that you'll know been
sorry okay so we're so essentially what
we did though we are doing and still
very much in the working it's combining
three different components which I
believe are really as in all important
to understand the story first one is
really were thinking about statistical
learning theory so as I already said I
mean the fact the fact that we are
moving from relatively small problems
you know hundreds of inputs of thousands
of inputs to very large problems and
millions and hundreds of millions of
inputs is they should take us from that
what we call parkour probably
approximately correct like theory which
was essentially started in 1982 with the
work of less valiant and and and then
merged with the work of buttnik and a
few others in Russia and others
centuries giving us the dream of
statisticians I mean bound on the
generation error on the probability of
making an arrow outside your training
data in a way which is independent of
the problem itself independently
distribution and then depends only on
something which we call the hypothesis
class or the complexity of the algorithm
the the function that we can approximate
and this looks like you know a beautiful
and very elegant way of thinking about
learning and it's still very elegant
question is it useful so I actually
argued that one of the mistakes that
people are doing with be playing is they
focus on the hypothesis class what what
type of functions this layers this
networks can actually approximate what
they call the explosivity of the
networks which is essentially trying to
fit neural networks into the old
framework of distribution independent
bounds and whether we like it or not
these bounds don't work and they don't
tell us anything about the actual
complexity
of the problem the actual sample
complexity of the problem I mean which
means how many examples you actually
need in order to generalize well and
what I suggest is to shift them to what
I call input compression bound which are
distribution specific they depend on the
problem with the independent of the
architecture of the machine in some in
some very fluid which is the focus from
the X facility of what these networks
and actually feed to something different
which is really data dependent or
problem dependent but architecture
independent and therefore if I'm right
this should hold not only for deep
neural networks but for anything that
learns this problem including our brain
if you talk about the same visual
problems they're the same speech problem
or whatever it is no the second
ingredient which has to do with this
large-scale prom we we should go back to
what we call typical behavior and not to
worst-case behavior and and since the
problems are large there is some sort of
measure concentration that we all know
from statistical mechanics of an
information theory which holds for this
type of problems under some technical
condition which I will tell something
they don't give out but then once you go
back to typical inputs not just dot the
worst case input I really don't care if
I miss classify a very distorted image I
mean no one complained complain the word
I want to classify the typical what they
usually see and and they're just like I
don't care if I you know have an
accident with an autonomous car and
they're in a very extreme conditions
that anyone no nobody confuse super see
I I really care about the bug and the
larger the problem and the more
important it is so luckily we actually
have a theoretical understanding of
large problems under some conditions and
this measure concentration on this the
fact that eventually when the firmly
come very large it actually controlled
by very few parameters is telling us
here now the third ingredient I mean are
actually information theory
alone is not telling us anything about
the computational complexity of the
phone and argue again why but so
we need something else which tells us
and it's as important as everything else
in this story why are these networks
converge in a reasonable time on very
large problems and is there something
special about this stupid algorithm
which we call stochastic gradient
descent which is essentially you know
minimizing the error and by small steps
approximately it's noise is there
anything special about it and actually
yes there is there is some some you know
historical luck or conspiracy and that
why this particular algorithm is working
so well and with the two previous and
think that I'm talking about and
essentially it all boils down to the
idea that the network is eventually
compressing the representation from
layer to layer in terms of forgetting
more and more information about the
input while squeezing out or extracting
only the relevant bits and it turns out
that if you actually use to cast the
gradient descent due to well-known
properties all the properties of a large
event equations of stochastic gradient
descent which converge to some sort of a
maximum entropy or dips like
distribution this particular even if
only it's only approximately only
locally that's what actually happens
it's not global with distribution it's
different temperatures or different type
of of measure in different places of the
space but because of it somehow they
manage to compress this these irrelevant
details of the problem very efficiently
all right so this is the theory and I
really want to go through it faster
because much of it is and received a lot
of attention in the past year and many
people have seen it so so the idea is is
that when you look at neural networks
yes just a clarification questions so
there are plenty of neural network
applications where the output is sort of
as complicated as
input so for example a neuro machine
translation translating from English to
German right well the generative
approach is something guns and and
things like this which essentially
regenerate patterns as which is complex
in the input so I'm just trying to
clarify whether or not we're you're
speaking about what we speaking up to
those types of problems as well or not
not not directly so first of all
yeah I'm now speaking about the plain
vanilla old type of supervised learning
which has this complex input and complex
importance and simple of classic yes but
we have been thinking seriously I don't
have enough students on it but on how to
extend it to two guns and two resonates
and to many other things we seem to be
working in the opposite direction where
you actually instead of compressing you
compress and decompress in some sense
and and and this decompression is doing
something interesting because it's not
just at ignore it it's reconstructing
the features in a reasonable way so I
believe that in some sense reversing
this theory and backward I mean from the
output to the input is is is not it's
not so stupid and and and can be done
and what so I'm not going to ignore this
question certainly but I'm not going to
say much about less than self as the
simple simple things first now so as you
all know I mean this type of networks
say that just want some notation here so
let's call the input X this height
variable high entropy variable high
dimensional variable and the output Y
and this I distinct I make a distinction
here between the desired output Y this
is what what we call the generalization
the true output the desired output which
is usually we get only a sample which we
call data of this Joint Distribution of
action one and in many cases actually a
stochastic distribution is not a
deterministic rule even if you think
about it as the monistic in practice
actually argue that the problems of
which deep learning works is where the
problem is is relatively stable in the
sense that it's not very sensitive to
small perturbation of the input and
therefore and this
very very well well defined stats notion
which we can she's actually very for
flying machine learning today is it's
considered one of the better formulation
of generalization stability better than
VC dimension singles but but it's still
a and this stability which actually
gives us only a probability of the label
as a smooth variable not just the label
said yeah I'm just sampling a joint
distribution which can and should be
stochastic now on the other hand the
network is now moving in a feed-forward
way through essentially a Markov chain
of internal presentation that's till
first layer the second layer and so on
each one of them depends only I mean
after training only on the previous
layer so it certainly is the first-order
Markov chain and eventually the last
hidden layer a gem here essentially
generates a good prediction of the
original label Y which I call here Y hat
and Y hat is not Y because if they're
identical that I'm perfectly perfectly
learn the problem in general it's
different and the the goal is really to
get Y hat as close as possible to Y if
it's statistically which one the
probability of this label is going to be
the same it actually we treated
statistically in most cases we actually
use the log loss or the cross entropy
loss to train the network which means
they actually interpret the outputs of
delay the last day is a probability of
the name now because it's some sort of
sigmoid and and that's what we actually
do now the question is of course what
happens during those transformations so
I'm sure all of you know what
information mutual information is but
since this is not only a theoretical
audience I let me just remind you again
so information theory is an entropy type
quantity which is directly related to
the expectation of the log likelihood
ratio of two distributions which is what
we call the KL divergence so the the
cross entropy which has many different
names and so this is really a
fundamental quantity what is the average
of the log life yield of two
distribution and if I ever addressed
with respect to the let's say the the
top distribution it's not a service
symmetric this is a non-negative number
zero precisely when the to distribution
are almost equal almost everywhere equal
and from it I can derive a measure which
has a lot to be said about but I won't
tell just one property of two properties
of it
the mutual information of two variables
essentially is how much uncertainty in
one variable is reduced by knowing
another one so if I measure uncertainty
by entropy it's essentially the entropy
in the variable minus the condition
entropy of this variable given the the
other angle and this is the symmetric
quantity
somewhat surprisingly and it's just the
scale diversions in the joint
distribution of the two variables
respect to the product of the marginals
and again this is precisely zero when
they are independent okay now the mutual
information has many good properties
actually it's a generating function of
information theory in some sense both
source coding and channel coding but
it's say it's what I need here is
essentially one property which is known
as the Markov as the data processing
inequality which is if I'm moving along
a Markov chain like the layers of a deep
neural network and information cannot
increase so information about the input
in the first layer cannot be in the
second layer lest I cannot be larger the
information about the important second
layer and since I'm thinking about the
desired output like Y as standing to the
right of the left of my chain
information about the output is also
only decreasing now another immediate
consequence of this data processor
inequality which is very intuitive it
actually holds for many other measures
you know the instance variable is that
information information is environment
to repair motivation so if I take any
permutation of my variables or any
one-to-one function even for continuous
variables I'm not going to lose
information now this means that if I'm
now going to focus on mutual information
measure between layers and inputs and
layers and outputs this is going to be
my main message this is completely
environment
one to one remote ization you can do to
the layers this is the fundamental
reason why information theory doesn't
tell us much about complexity patience
because because those measures are I can
encrypt my data through a very
complicated one-to-one function and
mutual information is at least in
principle unchanged of course there's a
big question how do I measure mutual
information between eclipta variables
because I need I need somehow to break
the encryption I mean I need otherwise I
give you an encrypted image and the
labels no neural network today as far as
I know it's going to make sense of it
unless it has some additional
computational power to solve very hard
problems but mutual information is not
telling you anything about the principle
so there is already here in this
definition rich information some sort of
strong caveat or how do I estimate it
and in order to estimate it and need to
do some coarse graining of the problem
and you do some thinning or do something
like this which which is eventually the
heart of the criticism that I actually
get for this paper but never mind so as
I said I mean so if I apply the data
processor and equality to deep neural
network I get these two chains of
inequalities which means that
information in the layer is all going
down information about the label the
true label again the generalization
error is going down and of course the
first observation is that each one of
those layers actually inducing a
partition of the input so it's some sort
of if you think about that the layer is
discretized that's a only binary neurons
or 1 + -1 neurons then it's clear that
the same layer can have many inputs
mapped into it now even if it's not
exactly binary i see i smooth it through
sigma or some other linearity there's
still some sort of cautioning of the
input in each of the layers so it is the
properties of this partition which is
really important i mean and and
eventually i argue that it's only two
numbers that i really care about in this
petition in order to characterize the
the complexity that the sample
complexity of the problem so ok so i'm
sorry for again switching notations here
but so just
what do you mean by soft partitioning
just petitioning is a fight now if the
neurons are not plus minus one not not
hyperbole but something like hyperbolic
tangent or some smooth function like
this evening then it gets values between
zero so this is going to induce a soft
partition in the sense that the
boundaries in the partition are not as
sharp as no so of course here you are
getting into a mathematical mess because
if you're talking about one-to-one
functions and with infinite precision
then you don't lose information in the
in this one-to-one maps but in practice
it was finite precision these these
neurons are always a discretized in some
sense and this is actually quite crucial
yeah the non-linearity of choice these
days is rectified linear units right
right and they're zero blow subtract so
this is definitely not see yeah yeah so
actually one way of thinking about this
partition is that you basically if it's
blow threshold it's like it's not there
right like you've taken a subset of the
units and we've gotten rid of all the
information and the ones that are below
zero and then you just taking a subset
that you're promoting to the next layer
right yeah so so so one more question
along I just saw wrong with you when you
say partition does that imply an
equivalence class structure so there are
many different images that's atomic to
the same layer I see so every image in
this class is equivalent in that sense
so it's equivalent class time absolutely
I just you need to be a little more
careful mathematically how to do with
the soft edges what to get so the
equivalence class structure cuz there is
yes then you have to actually talk I
either in terms of probability of being
mech to some of the parts which is which
is a stochastic petition or two and
which is really the way I want to think
about it or there or some sort of other
what do you mean by that it's 0.5 here
and 0.4 here or something like this
probability is actually the right way I
think of thinking about so you so your
second point there about successive
refinement yes what does that imply
about the equivalent
less rupture okay so start frying is
something guys this is for information
theorists I mean so I leave it and I'm
actually arguing eventually that the
layers are going to successively Kosan
their presentation definitely cuz it's a
Markov chain like we increase the size
of music yeah that's right right so each
layer further away from the input is
closer across the petition because it's
got only merge of smooth somehow the
previous layer and and and therefore
it's it's going to refine our course in
the representation from layer to layer
and and and they in information theory
and very distortion theory we actually
talked about successively or findable
codes which are essentially codes that
successively we find the previous
precision by adding more bits to the
code and and this is actually or
something very similar to what we
actually see okay I'll come back to this
so another slightly different way of
thinking about it is to think about each
layer here let's say the layer TI which
is the same as HIV before another minor
as as being in some sort of encoded
something there's some code that some
sarcastic map in general let's map the
input to this layer to the value of this
layer which are called the encoder of
the layer and the stochastic my from the
layer to the outputs are called the
decoder of the layer now the first layer
has a trivial encoder and very
complicated because once we move through
the layers the encoder becomes more and
more complicated and the decoder becomes
much simpler and eventually the last
layer the decoder is just linear
separable problem I mean just map a
plane that cuts my my space somehow it's
a very simple decoder but the encoder is
been complete so there's some
interesting interplay between the
complexity of the encoder and the
decoder of each layer when you move
through the layers now my main
theoretical argument which I am only
very roughly sketch here does this apply
to auto-encoders so what are you doing
with the outer encoder is you're
squeezing the middle layer is so this
goes back to inspection auto-encoders
have this you know expansion again it's
kind of like reversing because you have
use the input right it's not like yes
yes but the knock of Chan is still there
you're not getting information that
would fit into this framework will it
fit yes yeah but somehow there's some
some something interesting happens in
the way you expand your image I give you
a caricature of a cat and you somehow
fill in the details in the right way
which looks like a cat to you but the
information about the input is not
increasing I'm moving along a chain
unless I have some feedback connections
by the way we click the connections
don't have this theory though as long as
the next flow of information is and of
course lateral connection dog of blood
have neither I mean they don't send them
a call unity of this so so actually
audio and I know that this sounds like
crazy to many people and that it's only
the mutual information of the encoder
and the decoder of the layer which
really is very important eventually for
large enough problems for protocols
typical typically large inputs now which
means okay I am soaring away the
complexity of the problem completely
focusing on two numbers per layer only
how much information mutual information
it contains on the input on average I
mean this is average of all inputs of
course this is a statistical measure
which it it's not easy to estimate in a
hard problem in large problems and and
how much information it contains about
the other no it's actually what I'm
saying is that the mutual information
about the output the desired output the
true label is essentially controlling of
bounding the the generalization error so
if this is high at the generation is low
and this becomes tight for large enough
problems in some sense in a sense which
is quite becomes very clear to them and
then so the log loss in some sense is a
good bound on every reasonable loss that
you can imagine and if this is low which
means high information then then I'm
good with any other measure of occurs
okay the second one the second argument
which is harder to grasp is that the
mutual information from the input to the
layer is actually governing the complex
the sample complexity how many examples
are the lower it is the lower the number
of examples I need you know
to generalize one so essentially it's
the last hidden layer which is going to
induce the most compression of the
problem and so it's this property is the
encoder mutual information of the last
hidden layer and the decoder mutual
information of the last idle layer which
essentially governed the sample
complexity of the problem I don't need
to know anything else so this is the
layer any one of the layers but in this
particular statement it's the last
hidden last isn't it yeah okay so I want
to justify this this bold claim yeah I
know I'm now playing gold and I'm
playing the physicist game I know
everything I know everything about the
problem so I assume that time I know the
Joint Distribution of X away the true
one and with it I can actually estimate
the mutual information for small
problems at least for that form then it
become becomes technically okay so what
I'm going to use all over the talk from
now on those types of pictures which I
call the information plan or sometimes
we call them rate relevance and trader
so essentially the x-axis here is the
information a layer contains about the
input of the problem and the y-axis is
the this mutual information that a layer
contains about the other problem and
what you see here is in circles it's
called different colors the layers of a
six hidden layer small neural network
it's too small too embarrassing to say
how small it is that's not important
it's large enough for some of the
typicality argument that I'm going to
make a good hold and this is something
I'm willing to argue and and what you
see in different colors so the right at
the top the top right here is the
essentially the initial layer the first
hidden layer in blue actually the
several layers there so each point is a
neural network
trained on on some on some data in this
case most of the data 80% of the time
yet it's a small problem it has only 12
bits of inputs and so on but I argue
that this is not important so
essentially there are 12 bits of entropy
to the input so this is the maximum 12
is the maximum entropy in this case of
the input and there and in one bit of
output it's a binary label okay it's
just vary with the probables yeah I'll
tell you more about prominently I argue
that this type of pictures are
irrelevant even in the end of the major
problem we see it everywhere now what
you see here is the initialization a
random initialization of the network
with Gaussian weights 0 1 Gaussian net
well net weight fully connected no no no
convolutions nothing no tricks about
about the architecture now it turns out
not to matter either and what you see is
due to the architecture of the network
because the network has narrow narrower
layers the information drops very
quickly and the last hidden layer which
is a dis orange circles have very little
information about both the input and the
earth now the randomization here is due
to random different random initial
conditions of the of the the net weights
and different order of the sample now on
the order a different sample so blue is
the first hidden layer closest to the
input and and orange is the last hidden
layer further away from them now what we
did here with a V then actually
something I did we started to talk about
with Noga
a long time ago is simply train the
network which to faster gradient descent
and watched how these different layers
actually evolved in this information
plan this is the first frame this is the
initial conditions now there are many
many issues which are already raised
just by looking at this question just a
second let me finish this basic
clarification
understand how the output label is
somehow there's information about it in
a randomly the last layer then this is
the form and this is the initial
training initially shion's of the
transition okay
now then though we see that this cascade
of random maps since I'm actually
reducing the dimensionality is losing
information and you see that the last
hidden layer has essentially no
information about the class label
through the network as well so I'm
caught I'm looking at the network
trained with backpropagation in the
vanilla flavor of it without a
regularization without anything I'm not
training it yet
and I simply look at it your
presentation at the whole layer this is
important not one urine the whole layer
is one random variable this is this
actually going to be important that next
in the section file and and and all
right if I had from some reason as I
keep all the layers of the same width or
do or even expand the layers then a
random and maps will not lose
information and I will see something of
liquid if this is because the the
network is has this Eiffel power
structure now so the random projection
to low dimensions in a central problem
is not going to give much information
now of course if I think about it
mathematically there's a one-to-one is
an infinite precision then you know with
sigmoid all inputs or with there's
actually lots of animation let but it's
not if you actually bin the layers
discretize the layers correctly and
that's something I'm not going to get
into but it's very important now the
second question that comes out of just
looking at this question why is it that
all these 100 layers seem to occupy more
or less the same area in this plan so in
other words why are they concentrated
I'll talk more about it but first of all
I want to show you what actually happens
when you start training the network so
you see here the number of epochs after
this is a
zero and I haven't trained the
networking now I try to start a
stochastic gradient descent training and
and what happens is that this is what
happens so this movie usually wakes up
people there so essentially essentially
what you saw there and you obviously
need to be repeating is that up to this
point more or less which is around 300
epochs of training now just remind your
epoch is a cycle through the whole beta
with the mini batches and everything and
eventually I just process the whole
training data through all the layers
okay this is an epic so after three it's
three hundred iterations of this type
you get to this point which surprisingly
look model is linear actually argue why
is it that we understand very well why
it is and and and of course it's going
down because of that personal inequality
again but what is really impossible it's
relatively fast motion to this point as
you could see all the layers essentially
increase the information about the input
so at this point I have the max
information about the input and then
from here on some start something
completely different
essentially they just so ok look at this
this is fast the fast converge at this
point and from this point all they
slowly move to the left and up and
eventually the layers all do this slow
motion to the left which I call the
input compression all of them not only
the last layer and the last layer gets
to essentially one bit of information
which is which means good generalization
good generation and so on if you think
the data now the first question as I
said why do they concentrate why these
very different layers and okay I get
they're very different neurons I mean
it's not only the connections are
different what the neurons of resent is
very different and why do they all look
like one point in this plane so this is
really the reason this plane is that
what I got the right order parameters
this is the it's somehow throw away all
the irrelevant dimension
and what does it mean that they first
move up and then they slowly move to the
left what in the training algorithm mr.
caste equality descent is doing that
okay so the rest of I don't know how
much time I already used but the rest of
let's say the next 50 minutes I'm going
to try to explain what's going on and
convince you that this is a very general
phenomena naturally very fundamental
understanding of deep learning and then
I show you that this understanding is
actually giving us some new insights on
the most fundamental questions of deep
learning why the layers help me what do
they represent how to fit an
architectural problem and so on this
cutter is because I still have
randomness in my training and I can tell
you already that the problem the larger
the problem the more the more
concentrate so this is a very small
problem input you know it's ridiculously
small for me but it's still large enough
such as soft its difficulty asymptotic
arguments work and when I train larger
problem and actually train today you
know six or ten and things like this and
we see even with one network essentially
the average of this club okay
so it is really has been the my own
focus for a while to try to explain this
phenomena and to see how general it is
so this is actually captured the
attention of quanta magazine in
September and this is the average so
this is the end this is a picture from
quantum everything just our picture just
put some nice labels on its am I using
it so this is a sensitive story what you
see here in in the green and lines of
those traces average per layer and what
you see is again from A to C very
quickly you see it's a very faint trace
because there is happens fast you get
this say what I call the maximum
information place this is the most
expansion this is where I remember the
most about the problem
and most of the airbox runs three
hundred to ten thousand in this
experiment I spent on this compression
or this forgetting of name okay
so again I mean the whole thing is still
debatable and the people all over the
world who disagree with this generality
a generality of this picture but we see
it in in essentially everything we look
at if we just correctly measure the
information and this is actually tricky
thing I mean how do you beam and or how
do you discretize the the layers such as
can actually estimate information
perfectly if you if you use values for
example it's a lot trickier because
because you need to bend into finite
level somehow so you need to take Ashley
the distribution of the value of the way
of the units not a which the units and
eventually discretize it a cognitive CDF
of this of the distribution that's what
we do now the question is okay so first
of all you see already all the
remarkable features of this
visualization of diploma networks you
see that the layers move very slowly all
the layers even the first few even if
they don't have to forget anything they
eventually move to the left which means
they forget information forget details
of the of the problem and they get stuck
in in some places I mean layer five is
the last one here and so on you see that
the the other layers don't push all the
way to perfect information they get
stuck in the middle yes forget details
yes it's the irrelevant details right
and I'm going to are your wife there are
here on it is this preserve the relevant
details but that's willing a small
subset of it it's a very tiny low
dimensional fractions the same manifold
that we heard about so often learning
from you I mean it's it's it's this low
dimensional manifold of data and I'm
going to show you exactly what happens
essentially please visualize in some
sense how those layers forget details
but those it's really fascinating or
striking to me is that not all the
layers go all the way to the end they
they do it
Parliament they get stuck in the
so some of those layers actually
represent more than you need and the
lower the lower you are you get more
information which is irrelevant for the
particular task it's only the last layer
which essentially is really squeezing
only what you need so what does
overtraining look like in this diagram
just a second I'll come back this so
again
okay so now you can ask all sorts of
questions um so first of all of course
why why compression helps okay
I thought it's quite obvious but it's
not I mean that why losing information
about the input is actually helping
generalization okay so so here I have
some theoretical arguments which I'm not
sure I want I'll say them anyway so so
the classical generalization bound like
bounds I mean if you use all the time in
learning I mean those are those type of
bounds these are this have essentially
this type of structure the generation
error which is epsilon which means the
probability of making an error out of my
training data a square in most cases
with really holding inequality of the
children is bounded by the log of the
cardinality of the hypothesis class what
is the process class those functions
that can be approximated by my my
network okay this is the classical
theory so now if you learn rectangles in
the plane this a rectangle if you learn
circles these are circles and so on and
the higher the complexity of this class
the more functions you can approximate
and therefore it's the logarithm of the
number of functions in this class this
is true for finest classes but usually
we don't have finite classes so we
approximate them with what we call an
epsilon grade or an epsilon
approximation we find epsilon cover of
my hypothesis class respect with spheres
such that the probability of mislabeling
to a bottle of disagree with the
hypothesis in this in this sphere is
less than Epsilon and what we actually
put there is the cardinality of the
epsilon cover of night
now the dominant the factors they are
this is the log of the cardinality of
the clip of the cover divided by the
number of training example which is in
its the classical theory now in general
we have this very nice dimensionality
argument that tell us and that we can if
we can cover the if the class has some
sort of a finite dimensionality it can
be a VC dimension or Houser dimension or
shattering dimension or polar dimension
or whatever there many many different
names that which essentially tell you
the same thing if you can cover it with
phase of size Epsilon usually if it has
dimension D the cardinality of the cover
scales like 1 over X into the dimension
again mathematicians you know this very
realm in line these one plane these two
this can be fractional dimension this
can be many things ok now so we will
plug this one away from to the D in this
log cardinality bound you get D over m
as the main factor ok so this is nice as
long as the number of examples smaller
than the dimension of the hypothesis
class you don't generalize once enough
examples great like get larger than then
B and this bounds become meaningful very
nice this is the essence of learning
theory lesson today the confidence is
there is nothing that such a stations
really worried about is the probability
that you actually got a very bad sample
so the whole thing is true with
probability 1 minus Delta now once you
get to very very large data sets as we
actually do the probability of getting
10 million non-typical images of the
wrong sample a bed size is zero forget
about but even if you want if you put
the Delta to be 10 to the minus 10 okay
so this is 10 compared to M which is
millions okay so this is not this is
negligible it's really not good although
in learning theory really right to keep
this Delta all over the place because it
makes us happy not mathematically happy
for last problems this is completely not
important no but what is really
important is that this type of analysis
this type of bounds don't think to work
for the floor networks I mean they don't
give us anything useful as such we just
see
I mean if you look at the not the base
dimension of the neural network is of
the order of the number of weights with
these convolutions and there are many
other reductions so it's not the number
four it's the number of weights spirit
anomalies oh I don't know it's something
oh I don't know something but it's it's
it's it's much larger than all the fun
if you larger than the number of
examples which are also large so we have
10 million their parameters and we have
under thousands of examples and we
already generalize very well so this
doesn't explain why they generalize one
so essentially what I suggest and it's
it turned out to relate to what other
people suggested before me and which is
the compression bounds the sense of
stability bounds and many other things
is that instead of thinking about that
part of this class let's think about all
the functions okay so write all the
boolean functions from X the number of
functions to to the carnality of X this
is that if you plug this in the log you
get that the number of examples of the
order of the carnality of X know so
instead of thinking about reduction of
the class by simplifying therefore this
class let's simplify the input so let's
cover the input by my sphere so think
about X as the input as this is the
custom input and now I I practice in it
as exactly the neural networks do into
cells
and imagine that somehow miraculously I
know how to partition this into cells
such the probability of mislabeling two
samples in the same cell is smaller than
if some epsilon okay so this agreements
within a cell so this is not something
like a sampling theorem I mean I think
about in Mike recently I don't need to
sample every point and a function if
it's been limited and it's only the
sample it in same frequency and all the
other so essentially there are only very
few functions very few value of the
function no it's not necessary geometric
cells not inserted geometric zones so
again the question is what determines
the size of the cell is a very important
question
but so essentially I'm saying here let's
move from the cardinality bounds of the
the hypothesis class-based bounds to
what I called compression bounds and
essentially it's the partition so now I
need essentially one label per cell
after epsilon accuracy so the number of
label the number of functions that I now
have essentially if you came by that's
piecewise constant within a cell it's
it's now two to the cardinality of the
partition not to serenity of the input
so I caused and the input which is
precisely what neural nets do now
if this is true then you see that okay
so it moves from the chronology of X to
the grantee of T this doesn't look like
a very dramatic thing unless something
else happens so again I need a needle to
appreciate this notion of typicality in
what I'm saying now so I hope you all
know but for large enough problems and
the Sun conditions like that allow me to
factorize the distribution so for
example Markov random fields hidden
Markov models all the graphical models
with some sort of bounded average degree
I mean essentially that infinitely all
the physical model design with torn
images or it's only finite interactions
neighbors and so on so all these
problems are essentially factorizable in
the sense that if I let take the log of
the probability of a pattern it looks
like a sum of conditional conditionally
independent terms so this is beautiful
these are precisely the conditions under
which one over n the log of the
probability is converging in a large and
limit to some something which usually
called the entropy of the source this is
the McMillan Chen McMillan entropy okay
so this is precisely the condition under
which information theory works usually
we think about in terms of sequences in
time but here I think about it in terms
of pattern itself so think of an image
as if it's made out of patches so the
probability of pixel an image is almost
completely determined by the neighbors
so I can write the probability of an
image is the product of many condition
dependent probabilities now so I have
this limit so the entropy
now what because typical images are
precisely the cases
this limit exists and I'm close enough
to the limit and turns out that almost
everything is close enough to the limit
in the large n limit if so the number of
patches of my input is is 100 thousand
I'm very much in this asymptotic region
so this is set a limit theorem
essentially so the probability of each
of these typical patterns is constant
it's actually 2 to the minus the entropy
to end here and if I also assume that
those partitions are also typical in
some sense and this is actually a tricky
part and then the probability of each
partition is 2 to the minus conditional
entropy of this petition
so using this classical information
theoretic argument I can now estimate
the cardinality of the petition so the
number of typical functions when X is 2
2 the entropy of X I I suppress n here
doesn't matter it's in age and then the
number of the typical size or the
average size of a partition is 2 to the
conditional entropy of edge-on so the
size of the partition is 2 to the H
divided by 2 to the H X given T which is
2 to the I X T ok ok that's beautiful
that's channel ok but now I'm using it a
in such a different way so I know that
the cardinality of the petition is 2 to
the mutual information for typical
patterns between the petition and the
input so plugging this in the above line
I get 2 to the 2 to the R now this
double experiment is is something
miraculous because now if I put it back
in the log on the left hand side I get a
bound which looks like epsilon square is
bounded by 2 to the mutual information
between the input and the partition
divided by number of examples ok some of
you may think a conversion is fine but
let that means that every bit of
compression of the representation is
equivalent to doubling the size of the
data K bits of compression is like
multiplying the size of the training
data by 2 to the K so that's traffic
that's much better than reducing the
dimensionality just linear there there's
exponentially better than dimension ok
of course
when people see this say okay so is very
small there's ice very small it's the
log of the design of training data and
indeed I is actually the minimum number
of years no questions or what we call
queries optimally specify for your data
so this is really how many bits I really
need to know in order to identify the
pattern and this is just the size of a
code slope of the cipher date okay so
this is to me a rather convincing
argument that reducing the information
between the x and t is a useful thing
for transition and we can get to this in
a much more rigorous rigorous ways I
just don't have the time for it okay so
it is the information plan that we are
interested in so the next question is
what are the ultimate bounds in this
information plan which can't have any
representation whatsoever and this is
where the idea of the information button
comes in so essentially we have been
thinking about this as I said for many
years and it's it boils down to a very
simple variational problem try to
minimize the mutual information in the
representation so X hat is just the
notation of information theory but it's
the same as T and H here so I'm trying
to minimize the information about the
input while keeping information about
the input the output at some level now
this is a well-defined a variation
problem and surprisingly actually has
some interesting course itself a very
simple way of solving it although it's a
and B hard in general but never mind
that because but it boils down to some
sort of clustering yes that's why we are
here as long as I'm not thrown away yeah
to me this seems from the perspective of
a bound it's usually pessimistic because
it's really saying that you know my
thumb this is like my generalization
error saying that you know really the
generalization error is quite cute
trying to go back to the I know so this
becomes interesting when I is smaller
than log M yeah argue why it's small
yeah and it's going to be small because
the Casagrande and descent is going to
reduce yes yes yes that's the whole
point but what I'm saying is that
reducing I about the input is
exponentially more efficient
organization than reducing the
dimensionality of the class ok now so
again you can solve this problem and we
did it a long time ago and that's right
no it's it but I'm instead of thinking
about the nationality I pause this class
and thinking about how well I can
compress my input now that's to give you
some different intuition I said before
that it seems that neural networks
actually work for problems which are
stable in the sense that if I add some
small noise to the input it doesn't
change the label now this is generally
accepted as this robustness criterion on
this stability criterion as true I mean
so let's say if I am trying to learn a
parity function which is inherently
unstable
I mean changing one bit in the input is
changing it has a probability of
randomizing or I am trying to learn an
encrypted beta or something like this
this is unstable even if I have a linear
algorithm to solve it and it's extremely
sensitive to small small noise these
things are not good according to this
thinking at least the theory for
definitely not ever going to solve it
now if you add noise to the input it
means that there's some sort of
partitioning of the input all those
cells which are just slightly perturbed
in the right dimensions which I can
group into these cells so stability and
compression bounds are very closely
related and actually they can be
compression bounds not with stability to
be some other argument so this I
actually this is a much more general
argument but ok so so how do you solve
this a variational problem what is the
ultimate bound in this plan beyond which
you cannot have any represent
so this depends only and only on the
direct distribution of x and y there's
nothing else there I don't care about
the algorithm I don't care about the
architecture I don't care if it's
happening in the in the brain or in
their own deep mind now it's a it's and
this bound is something which nobody can
synchro summon if you get an alien
civilization it will not learn it better
than this model okay so now this bound
is this black line here this black this
bound is some sort of a of a rate
distortion function which means
information it's an information
theoretic bound about this black line
there are no representation whatsoever
below this black line you can have
everything and my argument our argument
is that a variant you can't actually
calculate this black line by some sort
of so consistent equations which
essentially amount to alternating
between the encoder and the decoder
until something like a.m. until
convergence and we know how to prove yes
this is this is a variation of the rate
distortion function in chef Shannon or
the and the algorithm is the variation
of the blotter Emoto algorithm for
calculating rate distortion function if
you want eeehm or alternating projection
algorithms the many many ways of
thinking about now this picture is a bit
exaggerated I mention this is a very
stochastic problem just to enhance them
so the black line really goes down very
shot but another problem I saw before
there was some sort of line there which
was this bound now this this bound is is
tricking the many details in this
picture which I really want to emphasize
so first of all I can actually achieve
this bound or actually calculate this
bound only if I have infinite sample
which means I have the full data in in
reality as we all know we don't have
infinite samples we don't we have a tiny
fraction of the data certainly for our
drones so we we managed to calculate a
different bound which is this red red
line and this red line is what you can
expect if you actually do the best you
can with a finite sample of your
distribution okay this is very important
I don't have time to get into
but what is most important here is that
if you keep the the petition very fine
just like the first layers of the neural
network you're going to have a very cool
performance in terms generalization
remember the more information I have
about why the better I generalized so
the very fine partitions are very poor
and there's some maximum to this red
curve right here where I get from this
finite sample my best performance now of
course everything here is exaggerated in
reality the red curve is closer to the
blacker but there is always this I mean
depends on the problem of course but
there's always this drop when I go to
very fine partition let actually it's
very obviously very obvious to anyone if
you have a very fine partition let's say
I random I throw infinitely or many
hyperplanes randomly on my data and now
I'm trying to label them with very few
data most of the cells are going to be
empty I'm not going to say anything
there and I try to generalize on those
cells is going to be very very lousy so
I'm going to have very poor translation
okay so the whole point of the neural
network is actually to cause and this
petition just enough that I have enough
label data in all the occupied cells the
occupied cells although that actually
get inputs math to them this is actually
a tiny fraction of the true cells on the
whole cells because of that because of
low dimensionality of the data okay so
our goal is actually to get the last
hidden layer to the maximum of the red
curve this will be optimal training for
the neural network question how how does
it happen okay again I just and so it's
actually that two types of components to
my error one of them is what I call the
compression loss this is what you get
even if you have perfect sample all the
data just by compressing representation
and the other one is what I call a
finite sample loss which is the
different in there rather than the black
and this is how much you can get if you
how much you lose due to the final sum
so we want to minimize both of them in
some sense no okay so now I go back to
your question I mean what happens with
overtraining and things like this what
happens is fine I did so now you by now
you're all familiar with all the type of
figures so this is the infamous
plant traces of a neural network and you
see it now as a function of the size of
the training data so on the right you
have a lot of training data in this case
in this case 80% out of the two to the
twelve patterns and in the undirected
have only very few trend data fibers and
again everything is now average of a
randomizing training data and initial
conditions so we've seen this nice so
you see again what I call the drift
phase or the fitting face up to this
Green Line which is more or less a
linear curve that connects somewhere and
then you get this slow compression phase
which I will actually argue is
responsible for most of the success of
the problem now in on the on the left
you see that okay they they compress and
they still improve the information about
I about Y which means they still improve
generation on the other hand if you have
pull samples you see that the fitting
phase is essentially the same but the
compression is hurting you okay think
again is very obvious I mean if you have
very you try to call sign your petition
with very few labels the probability
that you actually can guarantee that the
partition is homogeneous respect to the
labels is essential for our argument is
very small so we're going to a very
coarse partition but very lousy
transition because you don't have enough
data in every petition yes my question
is this concerning really depends of the
pinning so I wonder I mean these girls
make only sense if you somehow call
they've been right because I consent the
petition yeah yeah how is the painting
done and how do these curves wait I hope
that I'm going to satisfy you I'm not
sure I'm going to talk much about too
much about the brain but just I want to
be clear here so ok so this is a this
drop of generalization with vertical
over compression is very fact is very
similar to overtraining or over fitting
or things like this and you see indeed
that some sort of early stopping is
going to avoid this compression if you
don't have an update so there this plant
so actually first of all I argue that
all those lines I mean where the layers
actually converge
the end depends only on the problem
itself the data-dependent barber the
independent oil architecture and they
depend on the sample size so I can
actually calculate theoretically just
with a large iron motor like algorithm
the the optimal bond and I actually
learn to argue now that eventually the
layers converge to this moment
Oh which means that they generalize in
the best possible way I mean this is
some sort of an optimality result for
the planning if it's true but you
nothing can do better than and that's
the tricky part now you see the
somewhere in between you get to
somewhere in between a line like this
you remember if you get lowered late
essentially this type this type of bound
or some sort of interpolation between
the red and the black curve of my
previous bounds okay so obviously
everything here depends on the gradients
of the training so it's actually very
useful to look at the same video with
the generalization error and what you
see is that the first phase which is
more less up to here the derecha arrow
drops very quickly and then essentially
you get some sort of saturation of the
error still goes down of course but very
slowly and during this a compression
phase or diffusion phases I like to call
it and it's and the error essentially
saturates it's actually not really
something it goes down but you know but
actually this is the right the wrong way
of thinking about the error because I
have to plot it in a logarithmic scale I
mean going from one over thousand to 100
million makes a very big difference to
industry and it do not see it here so
essentially it's the information which
is more like the logarithmic scale of
the earth so going to 1 minus the error
here log of 1 nice there is really the
right thing to editor to look at and
this is actually directly to information
but you see that towards convergence
they're essentially saturates it's very
small it's very small changes now what
does it do to the gradients so the error
gradients those things it's actually
calculating the back propagation
algorithm
we know through the chain rule go
through the layers and I'm very small
was the era's monsoon the derivative of
the error is just the sum of the norms
of the gradients where we live so so so
it's all very small but on the other
hand the mini batches remember we're
using mini batches we don't calculate
the gradient calculate the approximate
and all the approximation of the
gradient by essentially calculate the
gradient over small sets of the data the
meaning batches are now going to to
fluctuate so what I added that the
signal-to-noise ratio of the gradient
has entirely different behavior in the
first phase and in the second phase of
this compression and this is indeed what
we see so what you see here again this
is our network it's this Eiffel Tower
and in different colors you see the mean
of the gradient pair weight and the
standard deviation over the mini batches
of the gradient pivot so the solid line
of the means and the broken lines are
the external division mode to see very
strikingly let up to about 300 this is a
log-log scale after about 300 epochs the
mean is much larger than standard
deviation which means very clean
gradients and should be very high
signal-to-noise phase and about this the
mean goes down they are different for
different layers but the standard
deviation of the noise of the gradients
jumps and essentially above this broken
line which is exactly where the green
line in my information planar figures is
you see at that time and what I call low
signal-to-noise the North gradient so so
a physicist if you think about
stochastic processes the first phase
essentially at this rate I mean I just
push it in in a gradient flow drift the
second phase I'm dominated by noise so
this is this is the fusion now it's the
noise which is exactly the fluctuations
from mini batch to mini batch of the
gradient which seemed to do the whole
trick this is what is slowing me down
that's why it takes much much longer
time to move but it's also improved
generalization
yes so just as a strategy increasing
batch size as you get so increasing is
their new thing than always decrease and
better as its increasing the night right
so as your training if you increase
batch size once you hit that point we
are trained yeah when you change the
mini bed size they obviously change this
picture but not qualitative just just
you just move the face image it's not
only a first edition this is crossover
in two types of behavior but but this is
apparently I mean we looked at it there
and I was struck by he apparently it was
known already not only known I mean a
Tony soldier for example analyze this
this figure and in great detail but goes
to some different conclusions so as you
see this even this many bump in the in
the in the gradients is actually falling
to some sort of a flat minima some sort
of a crater which is actually flat in
most dimensions and narrow in some
dimensions which are precisely what you
want I mean those are the narrow
relevant dimension and they're
irrelevant dimension we are completely
fed because it doesn't affect the error
so and actually if you look carefully
and as I do in this in this figure you
see that the difference to it
convergence when I get to a few thousand
iterations nothing really changed I'm
still improving transaction by the way
although the training error is
essentially zero there's something which
a lot of people reported I mean you get
zero training error and you keep on
crunching this stupid back propagation
algorithm and you get improvement in
realization why are you getting proven
translation because it's the mini it's
the fluctuation between the mini batches
which is not doing the work and what is
really the frustration hit the mini
batches these are really precisely
they're going to it I have one picture
of Terry here and not a picture of their
here the background slightly different
this background is not important of the
elimination change so some many batches
are going to have graded in this
direction which is connecting you with
this background another one is connected
to different background these
activations are cells very strongly
dependent on the irrelevant dimensions
of the data now so I'm going to do a
diffusion process which is essentially
free unconstrained because these
dissertations don't depend on the adult
effect error
so it's diffusion process which looks
like a flat diffusion in all the
irrelevant dimensions of
now this diffusion as I'm sure all of
you know the fusion unconstrained
diffusion moves like a Gaussian with a
square root of T so the square root of T
sidebar as standard deviation so it
grows like in with like square root of
the time now it's the entropy of this
diffusion process which essentially
wiped out the irrelevant dimensions of
the data that's that's my argument I
know that it's not a matter when you
look at the signal-to-noise ratio for
the different layers you see that the
first layer have much higher noise and
the second and goes down but the signal
to noise ratio which is the difference
in this log log plot is constantly now
the signal to noise ratio is essentially
bounding the information between the
label and the layer so this is an
another completely independent
verification of the same thing towards
converging the information about the
layer saturates but the lower layer
having more noise in them okay so so
okay so this is just the answer to your
question about the mini-batches when you
so that now I look at the
signal-to-noise ratio
I'm sorry this this was shifted somehow
and and you compare that point this
green point the point of maximum entropy
in there above the layer at maximum
information about the layer versus the
drop in the signal-to-noise ratio so
here you see the signal-to-noise ratio
and here you see this point and when you
plot them when you change the mini-batch
you see that they all move but they move
together which means it is the drop in
the signal-to-noise ratio which is
responsible for the compression and
actually we now know solving the
fokker-planck equation completely so
essentially the change in the
information plan is completely
determined by the evolution of the
gradients so those of you who know
somebody for compaction essentially it's
the the drift and diffusion terms which
are determined by the means and and
color and covariance of the gradients so
if I know the gratis I can calculate the
information plane projectors
sighs what do you mean exactly batch
sizes this mini batch size I mean how
many examples you use in order to
calculate your graduate forever whatever
I don't know how to do quality otherwise
you can divide into small groups of
examples not all the things yeah okay so
so this is quite remarkable I mean it's
it's literally dependable you if you go
to full batch this is brain line and
some people do they still noise and the
noise is due to the discretization of
the problem of tag of the step size and
due to all sorts of other things but you
see that the essentially on the same
line so it is a much slower diffusion
but it's still a diffusive process
therefore even with full batch you still
compress as some people report five
nights what constant then eventually you
land in a solution where the
fluctuations from irrelevant details in
the mini batches don't have as much
effect and then you'll slow down over
there right you'll just tend to you know
that's not going to kick you around as
much because okay so I got to
interesting question so first of all
since I have only five minutes I really
want to compress some information here
first of all here is the evidence that
the layers actually converge to the
optional bomb now if you change the
architecture they converge to different
places but they all the first layer is
very high this is you know this is
stretch it's the inflation is from zero
point nine eight to one and and you'll
see that they're all converge to the
bomb okay so the question is why would
it converge to the bomb but so I already
told you more or less I mean it's the
launch of an equation which converts to
some total Gibbs distribution and and
and it's the Gibbs distribution
essentially through base law which
correspond with this bottleneck
compression so essentially the gist of
it is that this expansion in the
irrelevant dimensions is reducing the
signal-to-noise ratio of the irrelevant
component now this happens by the way
with arbitrary they're infinitely
managed solutions to the problem so it's
not the neuron again it's the it's the
layer the whole layer which carried
information I can I look at the
correlation within different networks
trained on the same data and there's
absolutely no correlation in the way in
the
themselves I need to get to the brain
stuff but but really maybe the most
spectacular will outcome of this
analysis is that it tells me something
about with the benefit of the hidden
layers so this is the same problem
trained with one hidden layer on the top
left two or three up to six season
layers on the bottom right and the stew
and again it's the color code is the
number of epochs so dr. pol is is still
number of a person and yellow is 10,000
epochs okay linear and you see that
there is one hidden layer you
essentially get nowhere I mean takes
forever in these dimensions to actually
converge to a good transition and
surprisingly when you increase the
number of layers you increase the
complexity of the opposes class to
increase the number of parameters
dramatically the convergence is much
faster
and actually we is exponentially faster
I argue in terms of in the layers in
number of layers essentially with a
sixty-day in the layers everything is
blue which means i'm i'm already at very
high information about the label very
low in the epics number now this is
something which has been reported by
many people not not precisely but people
have noticed it there's something funny
about this deployment what's the more
layers the faster the convergence now
how can we explain it using what I just
told you so it's actually very simple if
you think again about this diffusion
phase this is what takes most of the
epochs the diffusion phase is dominated
by an exponential I mean is increase of
this of decrease of the signal-to-noise
ratio of the irrelevant component which
amounts to a Gaussian expansion with
time which goes like square root of the
number of steps so the time that it
takes to increase the entropy which is
directly related to the signal to noise
ratio is exponential in the compression
so delta T goes like exponent of delta s
K which is the difference between these
two consecutive informations now imagine
now that I need to compress with one
layer
this is takes time which is e to the
some of those compression from the
layers so essentially what happens due
to this back propagation is that I do
the compression in parallel all of them
are compressed and they push each other
because it's a Markov chain so
everything that I forget in the lower
layer I don't remember the higher layers
so essentially this is some sort of a
train with many engines and the more
engine as I get the faster I move
because each of them is pushing me
further so I do this compression in
parallel so this already moves made from
an exponent of the Sun to the sum of the
exponents
well actually it's really done in
parallel so fill it the maximum of this
which really governs the time so this is
an exponential exponential boosting time
in the in this basic scenario so because
I'm actually adding noise to all the
layers I really I really generate this
funny effect that all the layers help me
now of course you should ask so why
don't you do infinite layers of course
this is an asymptotic analysis and I
need I need enough time and enough space
if you want between the layers to
actually get some leverage okay but then
then comes really the interesting part
of the story what determines the
position of the layers in this planet
actually I was really hoping to get into
him but instead of two simple movies
this is how this is multi-dimensional
scaling of the first hidden layer where
red represent labels by one and black
represent labels by zero never mind and
what I want to show you it's very crude
a very low resolution image but you
still see and this is essentially the
organization during the epics of the
first inner layers and you see that the
clusters become more and more coherent
in the center day they get either
stronger black or stronger red the
intensity is the confidence and but you
see that this is a very mixed
representation I mean so in this is a
two-dimensional
most dimensional scaling analysis of the
structure of the whole first-aider layer
during train ok so what you actually get
here is indeed there is some sort of
clustering into coherent wave
this is true and I pushed into it
because of my minimization where now you
see again I mean this is getting more
interesting but the clusters are still
very mixed
there's no it's not a linear separable
data and no this that's where six hidden
layers this is the first layer first now
just because I don't have too much time
I'm going to move to the next one this
is the lastly there are one before the
last hidden the first layer in this
experiment and see what happens here
it's actually quite striking
so so it's again I mean which are you
have some bias a problem so it's the red
and left atom on white are not at the
same probability but eventually you see
that in the last inner layer the red and
black really nicely separate and
eventually the right is to the right and
the left is the blackest to death but
you see also a dimension reduction and
eventually everything is going to
collapse for very low dimension this
case one dimension why yes I mean I'm
trying to put the layer in which is the
high dimensional structure in two
dimension preserving the distances as
much as they can
so the aphelion distances is forced to
be similar visualization but it shows
you precisely what I think many people
should have seen already that there is a
combination in the training of
compression into clusters of this
partition and introduction of dimension
you see this this is eventually get into
a line on both cases so this is another
way of thinking about these manifolds
that you've all been talking about you
actually see now how it is related to my
diffusion analysis essentially again I
can look at the signal-to-noise ratio
since everything is under control I know
the problem I know exactly where the
mutually the other information is I can
simply measure how much information
about every let's say frequency
components of the of the problem
something like this is actually
preserved during the layers and you see
that indeed the relevant information is
moved on and the error very suppressed
because of this diffusion process and
it's very nicely suppressed so I'm out
of time and unfortunately I really
didn't give you the the new part of the
story
she's also related to Naga here but
never
so again so let me try to summarize and
I'll finish with this so first of all we
have been applying with applying the
same ideas I mean this compression
without losing information because we
had this one principle and one set of
questions that solve it to many many
different problems on many many
different scales you know all the way
from analysis of you know the fly h1
cell with garlic and others and if you
did in the 90s all the way to annul
analyzing languages and occurrences of
words and that's what nobody's doing now
so and actually a lot of training that
have we applied to the Maurice motorways
program we apply to control problems and
I actually argue that again what the
animal is trying to represent is some
sort of a compressed representation of
the relevant if the input under
constraint of performance now putting it
in a reinforced of learning framework is
giving us getting us to control theory
in a very interesting way I see I don't
I didn't have time to talk about it but
but what is really striking is that
essentially it's a principle that goes
through all those scales
now what is interesting about deep
learning is that it generates this
hierarchical representations which we
call this successful definable codes
essentially each layer is just
cautioning the previous one and they get
stuck in this diffusion precisely when
the topology of the problem is changed
now as I heard your question before the
the problem was selected very carefully
by me to be spherically symmetric so
these are twelve points which are
scattered uniformly on a
three-dimensional sphere and the label
depends on some sort of linear
combination of the dipole and quadrupole
moments of this points so the points of
plus or minus so which means that the
label is going to be invariant rotation
star under so3 order now in this case
due to the understanding of the Barnett
problem
I know exactly what where those
representation chambers are called
bifurcation points or phase transitions
happen and they happened because it's a
very symmetric problem they happened
precisely when you lose one of
it is a representation of the sensor so
this is really nice physics nicely
atomic physics so essentially again so
there's some group theoretic structure
behind the structure of the layers and
that's something we are now getting to
see at last what stops and the diffusion
or what is holding the layers is as
change a phase transition in the
possession cluster have to split or
merge together which means another
dimension other relevant dimension is
lost or appear so that's beautiful
because we can actually have a complete
theory so some sort of bifurcation
theory like this which tells you where
the layers get stuck eventually in the
problem and why adding more layers
depends on how many of the irreducible
symmetries of the problem you actually
capture and you live so this is just
like water feeling that you see in a
Gaussian channel but the water fennec is
not other than dimensionality it's the
under-representation of the group so
this is another talk that I would love
to get at some point but anyway so
essentially what I showed you is that
information plane I mean this analysis
your information theory is giving us
quite interesting visualization of deep
learning it tells us something about the
advantage of the layer which is mostly
computational it's not expressive I
don't believe this the problem just
Network a rich enough to express
anything but the layers are there to
enhance the the optimization and it has
a lot to say about what we understand
about the neural networks in general
both in terms when you apply to data or
we were think about the brain in the
same terminology but maybe we'll do it
some other time I hate for the forms
that would but there was a biological
hierarchy who were deep learning well
first of all the hierarchy makes perfect
sense in some sense in some cases and
and and we can actually analytically
explore it in some very special no toy
problems ok it's nice I mean so at least
we have some toy problems where we can
actually stand what the plant is doing
in movies many lives not just one or two
layers now the other the other thing is
that everything seemed to be driven by
noise I mean most of this diffusion
process is random it is a random walk of
the weights now what does it tell about
tell us about things like receptive
fields or you know where what's the
connectivity is it actually meaningful
or not I don't know so I you know this
goes back to the arguments I I'm not
saying that the brain is deep neural
network and it's definitely not
unconstrained it's not fully connected I
mean everything that we see here is very
specific and they have to be taken with
a lot of analyzing to biology this is a
this is not a problem but what I'm
saying
so actually look you know how much
information actually preserved each one
of these knowns so there is complete
although they are very different I mean
I mean I look at the correlation within
the weights of two random choice of this
100 networks network we look and there
is no correlation I can't identify a
cell which is responding to one to one
feature in the data listen I need I need
this redundancy for this argument to it
so by the way things like pruning or or
no way all sort of regularization that
that specify the networks
I mean drop-offs I don't my name is not
that essentially so they actually yes
they they reduce the dimensionality but
they slow the diffusion
they slow the diffusion and this can
help you if my argument is right so no
so for Sep network connections are
expensive biologically so if there is a
cost of making a synapse then you're
going to get them buried in the type of
solutions so one of the things that is
very dramatic about the hierarchy and
the developing brain is that it goes
through these critical periods that
start from the periphery like v1 has
this critical period that lasts you know
four
you know in the cap for a couple of
weeks and then the learning slows down
it doesn't go away it slows down and
then the same thing happens at the next
higher level and that goes up in fact
until late adolescence when the
prefrontal cortex slows down so is the
is there any have you noticed any change
in the degree to which weights change
and I want to be very careful not
extending extrapolating from these four
experiments to yet but we actually I'm
definitely interested but I'm willing to
take their the blame and their sons will
fill me in AI actually argued that those
type of hierarchical presentations are
critical for any organization of this
type now so we look at the auditory the
audio system will be saline l came for
many years now and he is really very
found off of this of this stages of
course we have similar things in the
visual system but actually dota for it's
more complicated and and and and we're
really managed I mean this is an ongoing
work we started 15 years ago to identify
the auditorium variants which are
preserved in each one of the layers all
the way to the a1 so I don't know no no
I actually want okay maybe I mean here's
the theory I mean I don't need to train
a director for this what I need is to
identify the symmetry group or something
like this and then analyze and see which
type of the components of the symmetry
are lost in every one of the flesh and
which are preserved and actually argue
that there may be a very interesting way
of doing also for vision and you know
this is I need another life thing right
so it become visible story right just
there's still room for improvement I
hope and our Steve keep sampling keep
something super inefficient in general
let's not give something it's it's
random walks yeah right right right
right okay yes okay very very good
question of course so the first question
I get from the scientists of course okay
so now improve the algorithm I mean
stochastic gradient stupid I mean there
do something better okay so with the
direct insight we get from this analysis
is that worth convergence there are some
there is a this intermediate this until
intimate connection between the encoder
and the decoder on the problem with the
way we estimated we looked at the real
neural net we actually I argue that it
is on the curve on the optimal curve is
by measuring the mutual information of
the encoder of the neural network and
then compare it what in what is the
optimal trade-off what is this value of
better on temperature on which this lies
and we got very nice fit now this this
seems that somehow stochastic garden
sense is solving this very hard
information but no problem now on the
other hand I know I have this blood or
Emoto I mean I have this completely
different types of condition between the
encoder and decoder so why don't in pose
this on the weights okay so we're trying
to do that but now I don't know a
property material left but I know expert
on on composition the complexity there
it turns out that if you can actually
enhance this exponential what portico
lengths super critical slowing down or
whatever of the diffusion if you
actually make this instead of
exponentially slow a polynomial is small
then the many health problems are
crashes also faster than what we know
today and this sounds like you don't
have to be careful so so I need to so I
don't believe there is a universal way
of exponentially enhance anybody
understand but they don't this is
complete speculation
you can probably improve it in many
problems which have internal structure
where this type of alternating
projection is going to help you and and
I think this is very valid and very
proper approach yes so this analysis may
be poor points also to a weakness of of
actually a steep learning approach and
this is the stiff
face is this really efficient because I
mean what you really would like there is
to have a more structured approach where
you can say okay for example in the
example of Terry in different
backgrounds right to figure out what
belongs to Terry what pixels belong to
Terry in the background you don't want
to learn this in the diffusion process
you would like to extract some roots
maybe from other objects that you say
okay so no I thought personally I don't
think it's I mean you know that actually
makes sense of the background in all the
possible different backgrounds I need a
lot more data than actually what I have
now are images of Harry in different
illumination different locations
different and I need to separate the the
stable features from the unstable
features what you're suggesting land
unstable features okay no no I don't I
mean actually the fact that there are
irrelevant dimensions saying something
else and say extract rules that apply to
many objects rather than just looking at
all these examples in requiring this
diffusion process maybe and I think this
is much harder problem and essentially
what I want is is a very very simple and
I can argue that diffusion is doing it
for you a simple way of ignoring the
irrelevant mention sorry
actually what I'm saying is that most of
the learning in deep learning is done by
the second-order effect not it's not the
error itself is how to Decorah late the
differences in the background the
irrelevant dimensions so I compared two
images and say if they have this as the
same label that's something else
something is irrelevant the fact that I
see you in the background sometimes the
human the background this is irrelevant
so this network has to somehow and it
turns out that this but exactly this
diffusion process is reducing the
signal-to-noise now I think it's
actually very clever despite how it
sounds a very clever way of compression
it's compression by nodes now I know
okay the intuition is everywhere
especially information theorist by the
way is that there must be a very elegant
a mathematical algorithm that does it
better maybe I don't know
adjusting exercise so this is an
annealing like where argument it's going
to improve things but I don't believe
that this is going to move from
exponential polynomial and this is going
to change what do you say that is common
with the many I mean I don't have any
arguments is for them certainly not this
is but no I mean I think that what
you've got the right picture in terms of
the nature of the converge of the flat
minima this is this is very true we see
it also hey I I think there is a connect
and I'm actually saying look there is
some something which determines the
position of the layers they get stuck
now since my mechanism is diffusion also
poachers mechanism is diffusion in some
sense it's a random walk I'm asking
myself you know it's a little physics
background what is stopping random walks
or diffusion and my physics tells me
that there's something that you all know
for a long time there's a multi core
critical slowing down the diffusion I
mean near phase transitions the energy
free energy landscape becomes very rough
either due to entropy barriers or energy
barriers and that stops diffusion that's
going to so there's something in the
layers that eventually help them and now
I'm looking for
can cause roughening of the landscape
and and and now we see that in the
bottleneck problem the first edition and
these first editions precisely seem to
hold some of those layers now first of
them many face transitions you actually
move through them slowly but there's no
but if there is a structure to the
problem and I believe this
compositionality is directly related to
what I call the irreducible
representations in ladies I mean I can
actually factorize the symmetry into
into smaller groups of subgroups and I'm
losing each one of them in a certain
point in this in this process there may
be a very nice way of putting these two
things together okay do you think trying
to trade signals when you say that about
different tasks at the same time so keep
that on your disposition or just me
divorce and then the second thing is our
fee for dance right so start with your
currency machine oh all right so so
they're the recurrent question is a big
question and the only thing I can tell
you that many people consider now record
unless some sort of a Markov chain each
time and you can think it each layer is
a different pool of neurons which are
participating activity now and then
another pool is but it and and actually
the same neuron can appear in different
layers and so on and this seems to make
sense and in a recurrent Network can
actually have many many layers in that
we can essentially all the time of
reverberation in the network we are
thinking about it I didn't do any
analysis of this sort through this
information to recognize this now your
first question is actually important
because it's directly related to things
like transfer learning and and whether
you can actually train the first lesson
to be more general than this last layer
so I take an object recognition network
which was trained on cars and use it two
phases just by retraining so the first
layer is actually captured the large
symmetry
and rotation whatever components which
is true for any of the information
problem scaling and then the layer later
layer and code the more fine details I
think this is this is a valid approach
and they start analysis into but the
nature of which symmetry is left at what
point in the in the hierarchy is
actually not so obvious I mean it's not
always the yeah I have to stop okay
thank you very much 20 minutes so five
after the hour you have half an hour
behind